the freehold of Valyria and its empire
were destroyed by the doom but the
shattered Peninsula remains strange
tales are told of it today and of the
demons that haunt the smoking sea where
the 14 flames once stood in fact the
road that joins volantis to slavers Bay
has become known as the demon road and
it is best avoided by all sensible
travellers
[Music]
in A Song of Ice and Fire Dragons are
amongst the most elegant and deadly
creatures in existence at the start of
our story all that is left of them are
their skeletons and petrified eggs the
story that the Valyrians found the
Dragons within the 14 flames the
volcanic system on the peninsula is well
known but much evidence seems to suggest
that dragons originated from the far
east in the shadow lands beyond a shy
Daenerys in a game of Thrones is under
the impression that this is true she had
heard that the first dragons had come
from the east from the shadow lands
beyond - I and the islands of the Jade
Sea perhaps some were still living there
in realms strange and wild in the annals
of ash I it is said that for certain
the first dragons came from the shadow a
place where all of our learning fails us
these acai histories say that people so
ancient that they had no name first
tamed the Dragons in the shadow and
brought them to Valeria teaching the
Valyrians their arts before departing
from the annals Georgia our Martin
confirmed in a fan correspondence from
December 11th 1999 that at some point in
history Dragons had been all over the
world this disproves the valyrian claims
that the first dragons were theirs in
the 14 flames we know that at least at
one point in history dragons roamed the
globe freely according to the world of
Ice and Fire Dragons have also been
found in in and the jungles of South
Ora's their skulls at least and it is
also mentioned in the world of Ice and
Fire
that the Yellow Emperor of ety kept a
dragon in his court though it seems that
the Valyrians were not the first to find
nor keep dragons they utilize them in
ways that no others had before
turning them into weapons of mass
destruction dragons are inherently
magical beings it is said that they are
fire made flesh their lives are many
times that of a man as they age their
scales grow thicker and their dragon
flame grows hotter balerion the black
dread could melt stone and steel with
this black fire dragons are near
invulnerable to fire but not completely
there are cases of dragons being hurt
and even blinded by the flame of other
dragons there is no doubt then there is
some a special connection between the
Valyrian nobility and their dragons this
connection however doesn't seem to be as
solid as the connection between a warg
and a wolf the implications are that the
taming of dragons must in some way
relate to a magical bonding a bond that
is able to be passed down genetically
the phrase blood of the dragon seems to
add weight to this all Valyrian magic
was said to be rooted in fire and blood
so we can only assume that it was some
sort of blood ritual that created the
bond that linked the dragons and the
Valyrians initially knowledge of how to
perform such a thing would obviously
have had to come from the people of the
shadow who for whatever reason must have
taught the Valyrians how to bond
themselves with dragons as well as
various other arts including their
technique of fusing stone and even
possibly the production of Valyrian
steel it seems evident that dragons have
some sort of effect on the potency of
magic in the a Song of Ice and Fire
world there is evidence that the
proximity effects the potency it is easy
to assume that the number of dragons
would also have some effect this all
being said magic performed within the
Valyrian Empire must have been quite
powerful due to the amount of dragons
this would explain better why the
Valerians were able to conquer the East
so quick
they not only had dragon fire but
powerful sorcery as well not much is
known about life within Valyria but we
do know that only noble houses at
dragons it would likely then follow then
magical learning was confined amongst
the highborn the Targaryen however
seemed to not have kept any of the
magical teachings of the lost Empire
strange considering the fact that dragon
stone was built using the Valyrian Way
of fusing stone now lost the Targaryen
s' obviously knew at least some methods
they hatched dragon eggs on dragon stone
as well but why did they not maintain
the knowledge why has knowledge that
kept an empire for millennia faded from
memory after only a few hundred years
perhaps the spells no longer worked
perhaps much of the ancient Valyrian
magic only worked while the Empire stood
the castle dragon stone was built while
the Valyrian Empire still stood it was a
hundred years after Dainius Targaryen
Sproul see that the doom of Valyria came
down there is no evidence of any
Valyrian few stone structures being
built after this point it makes more
sense that the knowledge could have been
lost if the techniques no longer worked
if dragons are the sources of magic in A
Song of Ice and Fire then much of that
power must have been lost when the vast
majority of dragons died in the doom but
still the Targaryen at least had some
dragons but perhaps this was not enough
and also blood was required it is known
that the Valyrians would sacrifice
slaves to work their sorcery slaves were
treated horribly in the Valyrian Empire
it is mentioned that the Targaryen
brought slaves when they initially came
to Westeros but obviously the practice
stopped slavery at the time had been
forbidden in Westeros for thousands of
years since the rise of the faith of the
seven mullerian the dread though adult
at this time wouldn't have been the
legend that he would be a hundred years
later
so perhaps Targaryen less temperamental
than Aegon decided to conform rather
than anger the other inhabitants of
Westeros without the blood of slaves the
Targaryen would not be able to use the
Valyrian sorcery they knew however much
they knew with Valyria destroyed and
whatever magical learning the Targaryens
possessed now useless the last of the
Valyrian spells faded from history we
could only hope that there would remain
some traces at Dragonstone also would
proximity considered I suspect that the
reason in modern times that Ash I is the
main hub of magic is because dragons
have always lived somewhere in the far
east deep within the shadow lands this
has also suggested in book 1 when brain
sees dragons stirring in the East he
lifted his eyes and saw clear across the
Narrow Sea to the Free Cities and the
green Dothraki sea and beyond to Vaes
Dothrak under its mountains to the
fabled lands of the Jade Sea to ash I by
the shadow where dragons stirred beneath
the sunrise the current state of Valyria
greatly suggests that the doom had a
supernatural cause anyone who travels to
Valyria does not return with the
possible exception of urine gradually
after the doom
Arion one of the only surviving
Dragonlords rode atop his dragon with a
host of 30,000 men back to Valyria to
reclaim the freehold as its king they
were never seen again
the sky is always red above Valyria Hugh
Gore he'll are we close closer than the
crew would like do you know the stories
in your sunset kingdom I know some
sailors say that any man who lays eyes
upon that coast is doomed
Valerius seems to be a cursed place
damned for some reason one cannot help
but get the sense that the Valyrians
were punished by some force perhaps for
their cruelty and their own pride or for
reasons we could not comprehend
perhaps they misused the gift that the
shadow people gave them and those
entities retaliated by destroying them
perhaps it was the slaves within the
minds revolting and triggering the
eruption of the volcano through
practical or magical means or perhaps it
was the Dragonlords themselves many
noble family is contested for power in
Valyria each of them had dragons and
employed wizards it is said that blood
mages made at slave women and animals
and brought forth half-human monsters
perhaps through their own squabbles and
dabbling in powerful magics they
destroyed themselves and after they were
gone
magic at least in the West began its
slow dying
[Music]
[Music]
17 Westeros the first Raven is said to
have been let into the world when the
Crone peered through the door of death
in the real world Ravens are often
associated with prophecy in ancient
Greece they were the messengers of the
god Apollo the god of truth and prophecy
in Celtic legends the birth